Peggy 18
Elder Scrolls online Tamriel unlimited
is an expansive world with never-ending
adventures and unparalleled social
experiences this is your legend and you
have the freedom to forge your own saga
you take on the role of the vestige a
lowly murdered prisoner given a second
chance at life a great destiny surely
lies ahead of you but where that journey
goes is entirely yours to decide your
first choice is the identity of your
character the ten races of Tamriel are
divided into three powerful alliances
interlocked in a civil war choose your
faction carefully as it determines your
allies and your hated enemies you have
the option of four unique class
specializations
regardless of your class you will be
able to wield any weapon or wear any
armor in the game you can also upgrade
those weapons and armor as well as your
abilities while your journey begins in
shackles only you can define your
ultimate legacy adventure across all of
Tamriel ten provinces there are hundreds
of quests you can undertake either on
your own or with a group of allies
you can voyage off in any direction
exploring danger and intrigue in all
four corners of the vast open world or
join momentous battles that will echo
through history
you can experience the thrills of living
as an outlaw and there are opportunities
to improve your equipment through robust
crafting mechanics and just when you
think you've conquered everything there
is to master there are still new
surprises in store the champion system
activates when you reach level 50
whatever you're doing you're always
progressing
the Elder Scrolls online Tamriel
unlimited is a world of epic adventure
how will you create your legend
you